l'ambiance est au rendez vous pour cette
manifestation organisée à l'occasion de
la journée internationale des droits des
femmes
manifestation autorisée par la
préfecture de police de paris et qui est
et bien été appelé par une trentaine
d'organisations syndicales et
associations féministes alors l'objectif
de ce rassemblement aujourd'hui eh bien
c'était d'appeler à la lutte pour
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
et également protester contre toutes les
violences faites aux femmes comme par
exemple les violences conjugales qui ont
augmenté en période de confinement je
vous propose d'écouter des manifestants
au micro d rt france il ya la moitié de
l'humanité sur cette planète qui est
maltraité jusqu'à présent on commence un
peu à se bouger mais encore peu que je
suis une mère que j'élève mes enfants
seuls que la société s'en fout que on
compte beaucoup sur le dos des femmes
pour faire des choses est que au final
on est moins bien payés ou moins bien
traitées ont ouvert plus de violences
ont fait violer
voilà aussi qu autant concernés que les
femmes tout simplement et je pense qu'il
faut sortir
pour militer pour donner de la force
parce qu'il faut que ça bouge pas
beaucoup de choses qui sont faites et
donc partout où on va il ya des
différences des discriminations des
inégalités et en partie pour les femmes
alors que c'est pas du tout une minorité
ses 52% de la population française et je
pense 50% la population mondiale voire
plus donc il faut que ça fonctionne
et parmi ces manifestants figurent des
étudiants des retraités et des salariés
personnalités politiques et médiatiques
également qu'ils ont tenue et bien à
être présente pour ce rassemblement
aujourd'hui je participe chaque année
encore plus aujourd'hui on est en pleine
crise une crise sanitaire où on voit que
les courriers sauver sont les femmes en
général les premières de corvée et donc
je suis là pour leur apporter mon
soutien
c'est pour dire qu'il faut que ça change
il faut qu'à un moment donné les femmes
soient prises en considération que les
femmes qui sont celles qui nous ont
aidés pendant toute cette qui nous est
non pas pendant cette crise qui sont
femme de ménage qui sont caissières qui
sont infirmières etc ça vraiment
présente en considération en tant
qu'être humain tant qu'individu on est
encore dans un pays où une femme meurt
tous les deux jours et demi ou tous les
trois jours sous les coups de son
compagnon ou de son ex compagnon et il
ya des femmes qui meurent il ya des
femmes qui sont blessés grièvement qui
sont en fauteuil roulant parce qu'elles
ont été défenestré et qui sont dans des
situations épouvantables parce qu'elles
ont été poignardés il ya des femmes qui
subissent encore jour le jour des
violences intrafamiliales
il ya évidemment la question de
l'inégalité des salaires du fait que les
femmes ne se sentent pas en sécurité
dans l'espace public il ya énormément de
sujets sur lesquels il reste beaucoup de
travail à faire mais pour les femmes qui
n'ont pas pu être présente
cette manifestation a aujourd'hui est
les associations féministes ont appelé
toutes les femmes à cesser le travail à
partir de 20h40 c'est leur symbolique à
partir de laquelle elles ne sont plus
payés en fonction de l'écart salarial
avec les hommes